here we go oh we can do it put some glue
to it yeah whoa oh this is cool glad we
didn't call triple-a and took fate into
our own hands like co'tin huh I got it
Oh Lily look at this classic yeah she's
pretty got nice lines but nothing on the
suisse meatball here yeah how does
America muscle that car fought in
Vietnam
all right men here's my credit card go
get some man snacks you pay for the
battery I'm gonna go uh rap with that
engineer here see what he can tell me
good
Oh get some beef jerky but not the
pepper I've got acid reflux wash window
$4 57 cents I gotta buy beer with it no
oh well then I'm sorry our money is
actually for beer so I'm gonna get
schnapps yes we love this $2 I don't
have any money you have a card swiper
cuz I'll give you I'll give you like
$1,000 let's look for a hat for you yeah
J hat cool all my fingers should have
card swipers they should I'd make a
great homeless person I just carry a
card swiper thanks love Mike a tip you
but my buddy's going credit cards oh oh
and this next ders effect errs oh how
was the battery swap educational uh he
didn't let me watch but he's got a super
cool iguana inside what oh yeah you
should check it out go on the battery
run me hmm I don't know it was like two
or three or Turner but I think it's like
a hundred bucks no money's not a thing
to me anymore
cuz I just charge to the game and not
with that credit card you can get
whatever you want whenever you want it's
all like really basically that's all
alright guys about the credit card just
a guideline okay go and order liking and
screen that with the beers that smoothly
wait
Oh little guy we're gonna get ya ever
gonna kill this dude just get your thing
holy moly she's a big bitch worthy
adversary string up and go for it first
yeah right there's first come first kill
but I don't know guys
it's just a dude diving in the dumpster
we've all been there Blake it's cute
it's cute raccoon doesn't mean it
doesn't deserve to die because I'm a man
stop shaking you take a shot I'm not
nervous right now I didn't say you were
nervous well I got nothing
quiet there's animals okay you say my
girl catcher what whoa
that's what I'm calling my face now the
girl catcher hey Casey I got you some
corn nuts you've killed my raccoon